tonight I'd like to welcome our third
speaker in this series Paul D Miller
also know that's a little kid
Paul's a friend and a conceptual artist
writer and musician his new book rhythm
science will be published by MIT press
next month in April rhythm science is a
manifesto in which Paul describes how
artists use technology arrange the mix
of cultural ideas and objects of artists
his written work has appeared in lots of
publications the village boys swords art
form ray gun wrapped pages paper
magazine the list is pretty long he is
also a co-publisher along with the
legendary african-american downtown poet
Steve cannon of the magazine the
gathering of the tribes a periodical
dedicated to new work by writers from a
multicultural context and he was the
first editor at large of art by the
magazine of digital culture the magazine
that is unfortunately now defunct
currently he is in the most well-known
under the moniker of is constructed
persona DJ Spooky that swindled kid
which is a character from his upcoming
novel blow my blood the DJ said that
uses a wide variety of digitally created
music as a form of postmodern sculpture
Paul's recorded a huge volume of music
as DJ Spooky that's a little kid and
it's collaborated with a wide variety of
preeminent musicians and composers such
as Lana sonatas re3 vici Sakamoto butch
Morris Kool Keith also known as dr.
octagon Philip Reese from wu-tang
plan Yoko Ono and Thurston Moore from
Sonic Youth's
he also did a musical score for the con
and at Sundance award-winning film slam
starting to quickly fade poets Saul
Williams we hope you will join us for
our upcoming lectures Thursday April 8th
next month manuel de nada
Wednesday May 12 2004 Ricardo Dominguez
and you'll find our past lectures and in
a few days this one online by a video
screen at the digital media center
website we're passing around an email
list you want to be informed with future
lectures and events please sign up with
your email address very carefully won't
share with anyone
please join me
oh hey everyone how you doing hope
everybody's gotten settled in and you
were all ready to kind of roll here I
once just to start out by saying it's a
real pleasure to be here and the fact
that I can look out and see such a
diverse group of people from all sorts
of ranges and and disciplines is
hopefully a good sign of what Mark is
trying to you know build with the media
of the multi media kind of series is
building here first and foremost I want
to just kind of highlight and just this
discussion with a couple of ideas and so
I'm gonna jump into things but what I
always like doing when I start these
talks off is um you know just kind of
getting people into a mode so to speak
so just so you know I'm not some
academics you can be up here like going
down to the last atomic particle and
footnotes and everything so you know
it's a pretty relaxed and open thing it
looks good this way I'm an artist you
know I'm not you know a super hyper you
know footnote guy so with that said and
done that was I'm going to now part a
what we call artistic license and with
that I'm going to kind of jump into
things by you know what this little
device turned it off so it's a movie but
it's a different kind of movie I guess
so this is my trailer what you're seeing
behind me is a very one of my favorite
films detailing a lot of the origins of
early hip-hop and it's a film called
Style Wars which is a course it remakes
in a pun on the infamous movie star wars
star wars was a documentary about the
early techniques that a lot of hip-hop
graffiti artists would use to what they
call bomb the system and of course in
the late 70s early 80s this was a huge
issue in New York's cultural landscape
because young kids were trying to create
an identity by appropriating public
space for private expression the idea
here is that people were coming up with
logos to represent themselves using that
taxpayer support a system we call the
subway system and so you know we were
looking at a conflict of public space
and private
rushon to me one thing that's so
engaging about this is the deep sense of
impersonal personalization of of stories
that we're seeing here people would go
into very specific ideas around how to
create names logos brands for themselves
and the more that you could get your tag
up on the system the more that you know
the other people working in the system
would be able to respect and/or consider
what your work was about as a real thing
so the idea was to spread your message
as far as wide as the system would allow
but also to have skill technique and the
ability to create a whole series of new
expressions with the vernacular and I'm
gonna have to I'm gonna keep riffing on
this word vernacular as I start but I
like this as a fun way to begin my
lecture because you're seeing logos
you're seeing people creating a brand of
identity and being able to create a
sense of expression using a network and
what I'm gonna be dealing with as an
artist here tonight and sure walking you
guys through is this idea of what is the
new street what is the new network but
the internet so in hip-hop you know as
Chuck Diaz said so long ago hip-hop is a
verbal expression it's electronic music
it's music of urban youth culture but he
liked to call the CNN of youth culture
in its era the subway system was the CNN
of a certain group of artists that we're
trying to get their expression out so
I'm gonna I'm gonna kind of be a trans
metaphor artist here by pulling mapping
one system of metaphors and one network
onto another network today these kind of
situations and names and logos would now
be a website and each artist would
probably be building their own style and
trying to you know get a sense of
expression off of that so what I'm doing
was starting my discussion out with that
whole sense of being able to go from the
early sense of low you know again
tagging logos and stuff like that and
updating it and this is a recent series
of logos I've been working on so I come
out of a culture I went to school up in
New England a place called Bowdoin
College and did two degrees one in
philosophy the other in French
literature and as an artist
musician I always found that there was
there seemed to be a cognitive
disconnect whenever I went into trying
to again map metaphors and from one
medium to another
whereas now mostly digital media is kind
of rendered at all pretty much
irrelevant it's once it's on your screen
it can be music it can be a building it
could be an art form it can be a sticker
you know it can be genetic engineering
but the same screen can lead to
different expressions so this is one of
my current logos I've been working on
and you'll note I'm hoping that you guys
can kind of do it with the metaphor of
again coding again vernacular coding so
this is DJ Spooky as a kind of a logo
riff on the whole early rauschenberg and
Jasper Johns logos and targets they were
working with with their paintings at a
certain point of early modernist sort of
Clement Greenberg you know kind of
American high culture so the pun of
course is only if you get it if you're
within a certain vernacular system and
your system of references is hip-hop you
might look at it one way if your system
of references is digital media you might
look at another way you'll judge the
font you'll judge the style those trains
that were going by earlier our precedent
and so taking that same sense of tagging
and being able to create expression and
identity out of the tag has now migrated
to me at least on for my artwork into
the internet so these are stickers that
another friend of mine how many of you
guys have heard of that sticker Andre
the Giant has a posse probably everybody
right it's the face that's everywhere
it's the same face that's gone through
certain permutations and me and Shep
Shep ferry the guy who came with the
sticker we're very competitive he stuck
to the state the same sticker and I kept
changing my sticker and that's what you
know that's the way again like tagging
the system so we go from that from the
train to the sticker to the website
hopefully have I lost you guys yet I
tend to get very nonlinear so to keep
this kind of concrete what I'd like to
do is how pass out a whole bunch of
stickers and CDs that I bought with me
so if you guys don't mind if you got a
second I always tend to find people
relate to things when they have it in
their hand so I burned a couple hundred
CDs of mixes and printed up a whole
bunch of stickers so feel free to take
one or two and just pass it on there's
less CDs than there are stickers so
and take one CD and stickers I don't
mind if it's multiples so this will go
on as I'm talking but essentially you'll
get the idea of the riff and the pun and
the metaphor the image you guys are
seeing is the what I call the Napster
black power logo remix you'll see you'll
see what I mean when I when I get into
it but all right so here we are the
first images you guys were seeing as
this discussion was unfolding was trains
moving and again a kind of a network the
whole idea here is that taking the idea
of expression conceptual design and the
ability to kind of think in what I call
a transmedia format it's all about the
idea of creating artwork out of an
archived artwork out of a vernacular
system where you're referencing quite a
few very specifically encoded references
to things so in the 70s in the 80s
again and when I was a kid and I was
growing up in Washington DC I went to
school up in Maine and one thing I kept
noticing over and over and over was the
distinction between Concord High and low
culture so I want to start out at the
second part of my discussion with the
gentleman by the name of Vannevar Bush
no relation to the current dictator how
many of you guys have heard of this
gentleman okay a couple cool I always
like kind of referencing Vannevar Bush
at the beginning of these talks because
this gentleman had a kind of a
predilection for what I could like to
think of in the durian since you know
Jack's Derrida being of course the the
postmodern guy fragments all this kind
of stuff but this gentleman was involved
with the early war effort in nineteen
you know the 40s and the US military was
dealing with a huge volume of
information that they needed to
coordinate and so he tried to come up
with a system of coordinating the sheer
volume of information troop movements
material goods moving through all of the
US military's routes and systems and he
came up with the term called the Memex
and this is considered to be one of the
first archiving retrieval systems that
the US was you know kind of trying to
figure out just how to deal with mass
huge volumes of information and
coordinate and seamlessly move them
along so he's considered to be one of
the the precursors of the Internet as we
know it the term he came up with was
called a mimics
and let me move you guys into this
he was also conceptualist and some of
the stuff he was dealing with was this
idea of how to represent human
information in a world where the
uncertainty about information is part
and parcel of what makes it you know
work so one of the devices related to
some of his ideas was the the voter VOD
er it's one of the first devices to
emulate and indeed simulate the human
voice so you guys the voter VOD er let
me just show you guys a couple examples
of it here we go
it was made in 1939 right before the
world war but the idea was to simulate a
human voice and the Memex
later was meant to be an archive machine
that what you would be able to talk to
you'd say I need this file please find
this file and the Memex would have every
file available that had ever been made
on that particular topic available
immediately and it was meant to be a
verbal recall system so you talk to a
machine and five minutes later a little
magnetic tape or spool would roll out of
a wall and that would have all your
information so this is the origin of the
idea of the emulation or simulation of
the human expression let me just play
this for you and again you have to
realize this is extremely early but
you'll you'll note as I play it how
relevant it is now so that's in 1939 a
voice being played on the radio that's a
simulation from a machine that was it
was trying to figure out how to relate
to people or people trying to relate to
the information they generated
let me show you know you guys are
schematic here of what this was about as
well because it's very intriguing in its
own way it's uh it's kinda kind of
become a metaphor for quite a bit of
stuff so
what Vannevar bush hopefully you guys
can all read this he essentially wanted
to print books to record again the idea
of a record that was accessible by voice
being able to recall coordinate and act
as a conduit between huge volumes of
information so the idea here was to
create a precursor to what we now of
course consider the internet and me
being you know in New England in the
early the ancient early 90s I mean it's
funny you guys are all probably hard
core computer wired or slash Wireless
and when I was in school we did we
barely had a Lexus Nexus or telnet you
know so you can see I'm an ancient
grandpa better you guys here 33 if
anyone so here we are in 1939 through
the area of 1945 where someone is trying
to figure out a library of a million
volumes and how can we compressed into
one end of a desk right so we go back to
that metaphor of someone having a
simulated voice over the radio you know
good neat good evening radio right to me
one thing that's fascinating with DJ
culture and the reason I started out
with those Subway's is going and the way
that people have painted their logos and
ideas over them is that the archive has
changed how we represent and indeed
interact with the sheer volume of
information in the 21st century is
through the fragment through this part
not the whole and this is something when
I mean whole it does wh o le not the
band hole right but no Courtney Love
here but to make a long story short here
we have someone acting as a precursor to
a certain idea of an archive and when
I'm trying to kind of relate to right
here is guess what my name as a
performer is DJ Spooky it's a funny idea
is when I start out in school around you
know what what happens when you press
play and there's nobody there and you're
dealing with all these fragments of
information coming out of your stereo
speaker so um have I lost you guys yet I
tend to be nonlinear so just let me know
if it's too if it's too Wow
alright so we go from there and this is
the official start of my discussion here
so hold on one second I am I use keynote
rather than PowerPoint
but has anybody here to use the seen
David Burns PowerPoint book no okay all
right so rhythm science um how many of
you guys have heard of a gentleman by
the name of Raymond Scott anybody all
right now I'm there's a couple names I'm
gonna kind of riffle in as motifs here
throughout the discussion first and
foremost was that Vannevar Bush
gentleman who came with this idea of the
Memex and being able to coordinate huge
volumes of information the second
gentleman who I'm gonna reference is a
gentleman by the name of Raymond Scott
and he's considered to be one of the
first composers for guess what cartoons
and TV commercials and in again the 50s
the post-war era the Memex became old
news because guess what the US military
started looking for something they
called ARPANET which eventually became
the Internet but at the same time that
was going on television was going on and
of course influenced so many people's
imaginations and indeed standardized the
way people relate to the imagination and
I'm going somewhere with this don't I
don't want to lose you guys but all
right so rhythm science patterns let me
play you guys an example of one of the
first compositions of electronic music
for a TV commercial and this is in the
early 50s and Raymond Scott you gotta
imagine like how complex it it was to
compose say for example if Bugs Bunny
goes like this you hear did it right you
know to write that out notate it and be
able to compose music for a moving
character on a video screen at that time
it was extremely difficult Raymond Scott
is considered a pioneer because he was
one of the first artists to use video as
a composition tool so again this is an
early point and culture here we go this
is a first TV commercial with electron
music
it reaches deep into the intensity of
your engine
okay autolite new blue film right
these are commercials that at a certain
time in a certain place were considered
to be some of the first group
large-scale uses of electronic music the
TV at that time was considered a
compositional tool by the very you know
sort of industrial culture that we now
inhabit and call home all right so the
composed images for that and also to be
able to compose music to accompany those
images was a very early art form let me
show you the machinery he would Raymond
Scott would come up with this was called
a video look and you have to imagine
someone being able to play music to that
in the early 1950s so this is extremely
advanced if you think about what's going
on with video on multimedia culture
today Raymond Scott invented the
computers that were used to be able to
make music to accompany the images and
what they call sync to sound sy and C so
this is incredibly advanced but the guy
actually made the equipment himself
today of course they'll be almost
unimaginable you didn't you'd have to be
you know complete I don't know what
somebody you know but not Stephen
Hawking or some animal but and the
reason I'm pointing out these historical
precedents before I really get into the
meat of my discussion is okay Vannevar
Bush information archives huge volumes
of information guess what nowadays we
call it Google right back in that time
period it was it was something at a very
very edge of the imagination
it was the realm of almost a science
fictional kind of thing of being able to
talk to a machine and have information
come back or you know the good evening
radio audience of 1939 is now a you know
an Apple iTunes kind of little module or
you can have speak text or something you
know so we take all this for granted and
at this time for gentlemen to be able to
make an electronic instrument to play
along with images
and come up with again a kind of a
theater of television was incredibly
advanced so here we are in the 21st
century with your average Missy Elliott
video she can pull her head off her body
and say you know put your freaking on or
something right this is now something we
take for granted and the electronic
imaginaries come home to roost so I'm
gonna just play a couple other examples
but before I get into that let me let me
just show you guys some current stuff so
hopefully this isn't an all too
historical and let me just see if we can
hide keynote for a second here all right
one of my current projects which I'm
always fascinated with is this whole
sense of again globalization so I just
want to play you guys a quick example
and we'll just kind of get into it from
there this is a early flash animation
piece have been doing so here we go
okay so hopefully that gives you an idea
that's a track from one of my older
albums called riddim warfare and again I
like the idea of put having everyone put
their hands on things so what I want to
do is pass out a couple things these are
a couple records so I'm going to just
kind of hand them off this is a how many
you guys have heard of Saul Williams
hopefully everybody alright alright I
produced his last EP this was called not
in our name it was kind of an anti-war
EP where I had a cold cut there the guys
who own this record label called Ninja
Tune they're depending on who's in the
audience I might be dealing with a lot
of Beatles fans I'm not sure but uh cold
cut is a cool group okay Ninja Tune is a
good label so alright here's the saw
Liam's not a no-name EP this is some of
my favorite records here I always find
that people kind of get into things you
know hands on this is Mad Professor who
I just did a project with this is escape
to the asylum of dub and you'll note
there's all these cartoon characters
attached to the dub sound system mixing
board this is George Clinton making
copies of himself it's a long story
all right this is a very rare record
Robert Rauschenberg did with the Talking
Heads and it's it spins so you'll check
it out like that and this is these are a
couple of different records by different
artists so let's see this is a the
project I did with Mad Professor and Lee
scratch Perry so that's called dub Tama
tree this is very rare record which is
what I'm taking it up of a marshall
mcluhan he recorded himself and a whole
bunch of different artists and writers
each one reading different parts of the
medium is the massage so whenever there
was a different font you would hear a
different voice so he taped he taped the
whole recording session spliced and
remixed everyone talking and made kind
of collage out of it mixed with jazz so
I'm gonna play a woman to that in a
moment but
one just passed around okay this is one
of my favorite poets this is Nikki
Giovanni doing the truth is on the way
it's a poem about sort of existential
sixties feminist issues I guess but in
light of what Bush is doing with choice
these issues still come back so there's
that this is the 12 inch of dubbed Hama
tree and this is Basquiat first 12 inch
its project he did with Rambo Z who's an
artist who's completely nuts but I like
the cover because it's a metaphor around
a lot of the idea of scratching you'll
know Basquiat and his paintings
especially on the ones that deal mostly
with language there's always words cut
and scratched and kind of rendered to
the point of legibility you gotta
remember Basquiat start out as a DJ and
the way that though he migrated into
painting was on the crossroads of again
music and painting so you'll you'll see
on this one it's the whole idea is about
test pressing inversions and dubplates
which I'm going to get into in a little
bit but I just want people to kind of
check it out and you'll get the idea of
the record almost or the record coverage
sleeve is a kind of a blackboard of
erased words so that's an important
metaphor again language erasure and the
idea of recontextualizing different
images this is Keith Haring's first
12-inch you'll note it's all blank
people who have similar forms who are
kind of mixed back-and-forth with one
another and let's see the dub Tama tree
project was a remix of the optometry
project I'm gonna get I'm gonna again
I'm going very nonlinear here so I'm
hopefully not losing you guys did
everybody get a CD or sticker hopefully
sort of one of each and or both did it
most people great a lot of the elements
in those CDs are taken from very rare
jazz and rock recordings but sampled
spliced and cut up and there's like that
lots of mashups like I don't know Missy
Elliott meets ac/dc or I don't stuff
like that
anyway dub Tama tree was a project where
asked quite a few jazz musicians to play
riffs and elements and then sampled them
the idea was to be kind of jazz as a
form of sampling or sampling as a new
form of jazz so this is the
and I'm gonna get into this
software-wise in a moment this is a
project that was called riddim warfare
this is my last sort of full-length
album you'll notice all these kind of
videogame creatures dropping bombs in
New York and this was came out in 1997
and there's two holes in the World Trade
Center which when 9/11 happened my mom
called me and was like Paul look at your
record cover and I just realized whoa it
is a video game all right these are two
DJ Tools projects and hopefully as you
guys kind of pass things around you'll
note there's a graphic design component
which I'm going to get into in a moment
but DJ tools are beats and elements that
people then share amongst one other so
that you can scratch and use them for
sets and scratch routines so those are
some of those and this is one of the
first records to really use loops in
repetition Afrika Bambaataa took two
copies of an old Michael Jackson record
and just kept looping it back and forth
and this is called the death mix it's a
very rare record so please give it back
all right two more records and then we
can kind of jump into things this is an
EP and a full length of my first album I
was called songs of a dead dreamer and I
did this when a I was trying used to
show with Nino's a gallery the idea was
to take again fragments of many records
and create at the idea of a social
sculpture so I took quite a few
different styles of music and cut them
and spliced them up and this is in 1996
this is the Japanese Edition so you'll
note this the the cover it looks like a
paint from the street which is basically
I took the material that they used to
draw the lines on the street and use
that for the paint and this is the
synthetic fury EP which is based on sort
of geopolitics and sound you'll see it's
a map of different sort of economic
relations amongst different regions of
the world but each one applied to DJ
culture all right
so with that said and done I want to
jump into the idea of the story so how
many of you guys have heard of Alex
Stein wise Oh nobody all right this is
one of my heroes and hopefully I'm not
losing you guys with the you know giving
these people sort of name call rotation
stuff I mean
in Vannevar Bush Raymond Scott and now
we're up to a gentleman by the name of
Alex Stein why's Alex timewise was a
graphic designer
and in the ancient early 20s and you
know 30s he walked into a couple
different record companies and said you
know these cardboard records coverage
sleeves aren't happening man we got to
figure this out
so you go to you know usually if you
look at the old records they were just
kind of cardboard sleeves with the
artist name and so he's considered to be
the the inventor of the record coverage
sleeve as we know it and that's an
important design issue because you have
to remember at the time radio was
beginning to be more popular and there
was you're looking at the idea of a
democratization of culture you didn't
need to go to the Opera House you could
turn on the radio you didn't need to go
to the museum because you could get a
postcard or what they call a later
versions of a daguerreotype but the idea
of the culture of the copy you know
being able to use multiples of things
was beginning to become the basic mode
of culture for that for the industrial
you know 20th century so the record
represented a displacement of the
performance you didn't need to go to the
Opera you had the record of the Opera in
fact it didn't even need to get the
record because guess what it was on the
radio so for the 21st century you can
think of the NetCast the mp3 file the
ability to kind of share large scales
you know of information of files as an
update on the record cover on the
photograph on the radio and on that same
note of the kind of dispersion this is
stuff like Fredrik Hitler will talk
about is a German theorist of these kind
of broadcast mediums we're looking at
again how the Internet is reconfigured
the imagination and so the humble
invention of the record coverage sleeve
you know kind of was a shattering blow
because the first people to really deal
with the the record cover sleeve and
again this is why I passed out stickers
earlier is the idea is that somehow
painting and sculpture and all these
kind of issues where you have you go to
the rich person's house and have the
Picasso on the wall or you know Matisse
or whatever if you have the poster of
that or if you put the Picasso painting
on the record coverage sleeve what does
that make it is it become a multiple
does it become a copy these are issues
in the again in the art world and then
in the 90s Matthew Barney being a
perfect example he was a filmmaker and
sculptor who sold his films as limit
edition DVDs whereas any of us who know
about
digital media culture you know you what
guess what you can copy in two seconds
it doesn't need to be a $75,000 DVD with
the ribbon on it right
and Matthews laughing all the way the
bank but you know nonetheless the whole
idea here is that copies and the actual
idea of the original is under critique
it's under interrogation and DJ Coulter
has kind of democratized that process
and brought it home to roost in a way
the digital media the same thing when
you look at people dealing with what
they call object-oriented software and
coding it's the same parallel kind of
production process you're looking kind
of Lego blocks of culture being able to
figure out what elements you need out of
the archive pull them up use them to
create your code or your or your image
or your layered vector point you know
portraits and Photoshop Illustrator you
name it but graphic design the idea of
the remix all of these issues are still
with us in a way that artists in the 20s
would find very familiar
hopefully haven't lost you guys you know
yeah okay as you guys pass the records
around you'll see the graphic design
component has kind of migrated out of
painting out of the museum and that's
why I started off with the the idea of
what was going on with the network of
the trains
so again graffiti logos tagging being
able to have a system or a vernacular of
reference points all of those are about
shareware culture and in a way DJ
culture has become kind of a shareware
value system so again it's an it's about
the economy of exchange let me show you
guys - very funny websites that
highlight this kind of stuff one is um
let's see I want a famous face how many
of you guys this is shareware identity
at its best it's a very popular show on
MTV at the moment and MTV it's a reality
TV show where they find kids who want to
have the face of various famous actors
so this is the shareware face right so
they follow these kids around two
brothers currently want to be look look
like Brad Pitt so they're they're
they're remix and sampling his face and
putting it on theirs
so they follow these kids around through
the surgery process the camera goes even
to the surgery room while the kids have
surgery
and it documents it and the kids then
end up looking like perhaps let's see
maybe a remix of Brad Pitt and Britney
Spears on a Pepsi logo or something but
this is very real it's very physical you
know its sampling taken home to roost
literally so when you see or hear
something that's part of your memory
affects you you know this is what DJ
culture is about you might have heard a
song in 1970 and you want to remix and
riffle in that song same thing the same
logic applies to someone else's face
your DNA an architectural schematic for
a building you name it it's a culture of
quotation and what I like to think of as
we call the experience economy so MTV I
want a famous face plastic surgery as
sampling right does this sound like too
much of an outlandish thing well let me
take you to the next one here because uh
it gets weirder this is one of my more
favorite recent artists this is a
gentleman by the name of Steve Tanza and
this is a man who has now turned his DNA
into music motifs so I'm kind of giving
you guys some examples while I'm passing
out my records as other examples of my
own work and I'm gonna do a couple mixes
just to highlight stuff but um so this
is jino mixer com where you can go and
play with Steve chances DNA and make you
his music out of his DNA patterns so
again this is sampling this is the idea
of the remix it's all about this idea of
sharing but not just actually sharing a
sound or a record or an mp3 file but
your actual DNA code so this is just the
beginning of the 21st century and I'm
sure you guys being you know bright
students these are all people's stories
and the way they stories you know get
filtered through the various media and
mediums literally this guy's body as his
own medium just as with I won a famous
face is the medium for someone else but
these are codes and these are codes of
culture but not just a code of you know
whether you're watching TV or not but
the actual code that makes up your body
so what happens when that becomes music
it's actually doesn't really sound too
pleasant so I'm gonna keep moving but
anyway the metaphor here is that this is
code it's not multimedia where you're
sitting there and coming up with a new
flash animation file but actually being
able to try and understand the basic
structure of what it means to be human
in the digital information era so I'm
using DJ culture as a metaphor for all
of these things the remix sampling can
be plastic surgery can be DNA code but
the metaphor holds and you're looking at
selection and found objects so this is
something Marcel Duchamp was riffing on
in the same way that people like
Vannevar Bush dealing with huge volumes
of information I mean there's a couple
million bits and pieces and your
information making up your DNA here
these have all come home to roost so
with that said then let me jump to a
couple other things here I always tend
to find people relate to stories better
so let me just show you guys a couple
different things just recently I did a
project with the Oakland Symphony Bay
Orchestra this is me on the marquee like
seeing that one the Paramount is one of
the larger theaters in Oakland and
that's me with the conductor and we go I
was up alright okay so I don't know if
everybody can see the resolution this is
me and about a 72 piece Orchestra the
orchestra was playing various riffs and
elements and I had sampled them and then
made you know vinyl versions of it so
this is riffing on bolero and
Beethoven's seventh symphony I just did
this last Friday a couple days ago so
what I was doing was having the
orchestra elements scratching him and
mixing him in and having a conductor
play with the rest of the orchestra by
calling up the riffs by you know normal
conducting and stuff it's a fun project
about 3,000 and people came up to the
opening it was fun and on another note
let me just show let's see this is one
of the larger festivals I played
recently this is um here's me spinning
alright and this is about 50,000 people
out in the audience so hey audience
alright and that's me and rjd2 I don't
know if you guys know me he's like yo
Paul this is huge I was like yeah it's
fun the sound system was about a quarter
mile high so it was like you could
scratch there's like
she's this big bass woofers right it's
got to have bass so so you go from
mixing DNA to mixing crowds and we see
about 50,000 people hearing a huge bass
woofer and this is you know I'm not
exactly Paul Oakenfold or anything you
know but you know the idea here is
mixing as a basic sense of vernacular so
let me take you guys to a couple other
remix folks and again this is all about
just shareware culture so I'm just
riffing on things here how many you guys
are probably all heard of Moby all right
okay let's see I want to play you guys a
couple of things here and this is a
gentleman by the name of Scott Joplin
but played as biomechanical piano so
just think of you guys an idea this is a
tinfoil kind of thing with little punch
card holes at the turn of the century
right so those riffs we all know those
that was a mechanical piano you had to
crank it up and believe it not Scott
Joplin's playing was meant mechanized in
a way that was then made into these kind
of salon parlor machines and again these
kind of weird tinfoil rolls you know you
get a shipment of a weird box and you
have to crank it up and you'd have a
maquette mechanized Scott Joplin right
for us it would be a jukebox or you go
to a club and there'll be a DJ so the
pun here is mech and mechanization being
able to kind of think about that and
again 100 some odd years earlier and let
me just play you guys a couple examples
here right you guys all know that but
suppose I were to take the same riff and
change it let's see when we got here the
motif for me at least is all about being
able to understand the dynamics and
change them so here we are in the 21st
century where all of these memories and
the ideas are unstable objects of memory
let's see this is one of the first
right so most of you probably heard that
in mobis track which is this remix of
the same piece that's take that's a
slave narrative again taken from the
South remix taken from Alan Lomax
archive of all these recordings he did
of plantation songs and Moby sampled it
and made it I guess become an SUV ad
maybe so here we go
right so that sense of the remix that I
was talking about earlier this is one of
the more popular songs and you have to
remember this album sold about nine
million copies and it wasn't based on
the actual vocalist it wasn't based on
in fact any recognizable essence of the
provoked list it's one of the first
large-scale mainstream albums where no
one even knows what the vocalist looks
like let alone knows what they sound
like
in fact the vocalists took someone
else's voice and made that cell so how
do you understand this idea of presence
and absence identity and being able to
understand sampling as a representation
of collage the reason I'm riffing on
this is because I'm fascinated with the
idea of the uncanny and the fact that's
kind of what spooky was about I used to
go into my philosophy class and getting
these discussions about say for example
Hegel's notions of dialectics so you
could then say well suppose we take a
dialectical approach to someone like WH
Auden or if we take the idea of how a
composer will work with a poem or a song
or even just how we hear things so let
me just play you an example after the
moby this is WH Auden reading poem of
Yeats or poem sort of in the memory so
that he's talked about the death of the
poet kept from his poems I'm using this
as an example of like kind of the
distinction between modernism and versus
postmodern and how if you think about
let's look at the etymology of the word
phonograph
it means phonetics of graphology sound
writing so whenever you think of someone
like say for example local turmoil in
the French poet or you know the pollen
air and a lot of the French imagine it's
kind of scene or the early surrealist
scene
all those artists were dealing with the
idea of the standardization of the
imagination and trying to understand it
as kind of a cut-up narrative you can
look at you know Millar maze poems you
can look at lo Timon this is the French
scene or even what W C's ideas around
the say for example the composition la
Mayo where he heard a lot of Asian music
and applied it to classical
so sampling has been part and parcel of
the 20th century imagination but when it
gets to the 20th century this is where
the entropy really kicks in and you're
uncertain T of origin how ethnicity
relates to say for example if you hear a
South Asian song probably most of you
guys have heard of let's see panjabi MC
right let me play you like gangsta
hip-hop from India and you can get the
idea
right so we have deci crew in the house
hopefully but you take the same version
and do a different bead and this is the
same the Moby effective
so how many of you guys had any idea
what that person saying all right
maybe one maybe two but the idea of a
system of correspondences this is
something about franchise identity this
is about rhythm and globalization and
also about pain humanism and it's an
issue that when you're looking at how
music has spread throughout the world DJ
Coulter has been one of the ciphers for
people to translate different rhythm
structures and syntaxes to their own
region local style and again personal
style by tailoring and taking from the
fragments of various archives
and applying them to local situations so
that's why I was talking about the
Internet as if new form of the street so
the subway system that was started out
my lawn my talk with the idea of the
trains and correspondences and people
trying to generate identity you're
looking again public space private
expression digital media as a kind of a
cipher of these internal again cultural
issues as filtered through an
information economy again when you think
about mp3 culture and the way people
have been able to spread and diversify
all sorts of different again
compositional strategies this is
something that cuts across the creative
act whether it's architecture DNA remix
in or even encoding files the whole
system is about selection and being able
to translate across mediums so as an
artist this is something I've been
trying to figure out and so that's where
the spookiness comes in how do you
create identity as an artist and make a
metaphor out of that again instead of a
post Warhol sense of copies of copies of
copies when you're thinking about that
and what's come home to roost
generationally speaking we're probably
the first generation to really grow up
with this as our environment I read in
the statistic in the Economist did a
little while ago where they said
something like 50% of the world's
population ever even made a phone call
yet so we have to really imagine that
kind of riff you know on technology art
and culture in a world where most of us
are living in a way that our ancestors
wouldn't even be able to necessarily
understand except for the
correspondences between the familiar and
the unfamiliar so 50% of the world's
population ever you've made a phone call
one of my favorite science fiction
writers his name's William Gibson has a
great phrase where he says the future is
already here it's just unevenly
distributed so so this is where you have
a guy on a camel calling and missile
strikes on the World Trade Center
downtown or guy riding a camel in the
desert in Saudi Arabia maybe or for that
matter you have you know some people in
a village in India where there's one
phone for every 300 people you know
being able to tune in to watch the World
Soccer Cup you know hearing it coming
out of a telephone these are things that
you know artists I think are going to
have to interpret as we move further and
further into this kind of information
and experience economy because to me at
least the United States at this point
our best product is not products anymore
we the only thing we really do well is
produce more consumers so maybe that's
why Bush said go shopping after 9/11
right you know it's just one of those
strange inversions of the industrial
reality we live in so let me play you
guys a couple other examples I played
you Moby sort of sampling someone else
but let me take you guys further back
because I'm talking about networks
you're talking about history I'm talking
about interrogating history this is um
Marconi's first broadcast of radio over
the Atlantic again this is radio was
used to create a sense of collapse of
distance let me just play this one last
time
so that was Marconi making one of the
first transatlantic radio broadcasts
from 1901 but you're thinking about
again a collapse of distance and what
radio implied at that time has now come
home to roost in the Internet where you
can send a file so quickly you know
we're looking at the idea of the speed
of light itself as it moves through the
fiber-optic cables as being able to
condense the human imagination again
where Vannevar Bush had the Memex where
he felt you'd be able to talk to a
machine to us the idea is now come home
to roost that we now have a kind of what
delusion Atari would call a machine ik
imagination how we think about things
structures files surface level
components being able to pick and choose
and pull and compile these are issues
that machinery were assigned in the
early portion of the 20th century but
how do we in a post human quote-unquote
era think about that well you know what
that's where the metaphor comes home to
roost post human of course who was human
and how many guys have heard of the 14th
amendment probably everybody right all
right 14th amendment it was after the
Civil War and slavery and it was meant
to be a balance for the slave states
which had been previously the south to
be able to have the freedom of franchise
for the slaves and the slaves of course
were then given what the amendment would
they call equal protection under the law
but the most cases that came before the
court at that time again this is right
after the Civil War and half the country
had been shattered and the slaveholding
states were in ruins and it quantico
occupied by the you know the north well
the most cases that came before the
Supreme Court were all about
corporations claiming identity and so
the actual 14th amendment use was
actually constructed to give
corporations identity as people and so
that's America's economic gift to the
rest of the planet was the actual
construction of corporations out and out
of the ruins of slavery and so if you
think about how that affected of course
we live in the era of for the
corporation economy this has now come
home to roost
so african-american culture and identity
especially in the post-civil war era was
a kind of a crucible a crossroads for
both culture and the form of blues
Jazze all this kind of stuff that
migrated to the north and influenced all
of the styles of the other errors but
also in the way that corporations were
able to claim identity transform it and
use it as an economic platform to create
you know what they call larger economies
of scale and production so hopefully I'm
not losing you guys and this is not to
nonlinear but let me just kind of riff
on one or two things and I always find
people relate better their stories after
I get to theoretical so this is a remix
of some very funny stuff I downloaded
from it all com so hopefully this
is one that everybody can get here and
you know the punning and the sense of
being able to play with again public
space and private expression here we go
I hope you'll join me expressing fear
and selfishness you're erased aramean
death as a college in cream
we can establish a more even
amenity defeating not only the good work
of charities but the values that bring
lasting peace and we have a great
opportunity during this time of war to
lead the world toward suicide
that's one
all right so well whenever I get to
theoretical and talking about this idea
of the you know archive imagination and
stuff like that I'm playing with the
found fragments of you know digital
culture I always tend to find this one
is a good party trick right you know we
can all relate to
so the remix as a metaphor for 21st
century culture its aesthetics and
values let me just walk you guys through
a couple more things and then Mark what
you think we should open up the
questions I wait for time okay cool
all right so here we are with good old
this is my layout board again you got to
think of the what I call the Photoshop
imagination we have layers and vectors
we just put this guy in a certain you
know layer I could also layer all sorts
of stuff over him but we don't have time
so we could keep moving all right so
this is a gentleman staring at a very
small screen playing a weird computer
that he made himself
alright alright and this is a piece
again the sticker that you guys all
hopefully got was that
but again the metaphor here is about
play so let me just play one other quick
example and this will give you guys a
little bit better idea so here we go
all right so being able to sample again
gestures fragments and being able to
give them a life and breathe life into
him is again what Freud would have
called again at the turn of the 19th
into the 20th century the unhide look
the uncanny and we live in a culture
that's haunted by that and again the
spooky metaphors always meant to be a
sense of humor about again pressing play
and there's no one there you're playing
with fragments of a vanished presence so
here you see on the screen the remix of
the Napster logo that I did a little
while ago so sense of humor it's always
funny I don't know if you guys all know
Shawn Fanning he's the guy who came up
with Napster so I'm very funny little
short story I always bring up with this
logos that shawn has curly hair and so
he's white guy but because he had curly
hair he they said he had nappy hair and
so that's where you got a term Napster
believe it or not
now it's like sort of black you know
kind of joke inside joke there we go
but anyway so you guys get the idea here
we mix this is the black power Napster
thing all right there we go
what you're seeing here is one of the
first notion of a standardized time this
is the harrison clock from the late 18th
century the British Empire would like
the American Empire needed to be able to
figure out ways to standardize
situations so that you'll be able to
send products and receive things you
know this is their I guess their
equivalent of the world on time so one
of my most recent projects was a
collaboration with an artist named
Julian Lavernia I don't know if you guys
all saw those you know the two beams of
light where the World Trade Center was
Julian designed those he's an old friend
of mine but for this project we got the
British Admiralty which is of course
guess what we're Greenwich Meridian time
is it's based in Greenwich you know
England not Greenwich Connecticut but
they basically put a stethoscope inside
the h4 clock and recorded the sound of
the machinery of again standardized time
so I got a really high-resolution image
of this h4 clock the British created
what we call longitude again you know
the world on a grid system against
standardized geographic time and being
able to reference and put to
they're a map of the world based on
standardization which of course the
Internet is now inherited and made more
more entropic but it was all based on
the idea of a very specific time ratio
of machine parts so I got the H for
clock and put my own graffiti tags on
each time you can see at the bottom of
each number is a different graffiti tag
but again when you think about when I
was showing you earlier the trains with
all those different expressions going
over them as a kind of a starting point
for my aesthetic hopefully this will
kind of lead you to the idea of you know
subjective time so this is graffiti in
the post structural kind of mentality it
also has a similar resonance to Japanese
Kanji as well I don't know if there's
too many folks from Japan or China but
it's my own language not not so let me
bring you guys here all right this is
the United Nations model of the
standardized time and it's based on a
360 degree kind of rotation of the
planet let's go back here me and Julian
got the mikls panther who is the United
Nations chief karte ologist to give us
the map of all the different time zones
and this is a limitation CD by the way
all the images and sounds you're seeing
or at least most of them not all they're
all downloadable from the website it's
DJ Spooky com if you go to the arts
section the stuff I was showing you
earlier most of it you can again the
idea is that you could eventually make
your own mixes out of all this stuff so
the world on the grid structure as the
inheritor of the longitude hopefully you
guys can see the blue lines where the
demarcations of longitude that the
British Empire came up in the late 18th
century the red lines are the games each
nation plays with their time zones so
say for example if you're in China
you're on Beijing supreme time so the
whole country is set to this one o'clock
or I don't know Pakistan and India
really hate each other so they put
themselves about 15 minutes apart you
know little things like them but the
blue lines are considered to be rational
time longitude very precise structures
and the red lines or irrational time or
political time and the way each country
say for example Chicago they made their
own time zone because the farmers needed
more time to get to the market the US is
on three time zones you know it doesn't
need to be as you can see it's been
marketed by a couple different versions
of longitude again the blue lines as
rational time so I got the the British
for AB morality to give me the sound of
the clock and made a mix of it it's
going at about 180 beats per minute
again 360 180 so double and the sound of
the clock is downloadable from my
website but if you think about DJ
culture that the hip hop rhythm beats
around 90 beats per minute drum and bass
is usually around 180 beats per minute
so the pun of course is about world time
as beats and pulses so let me play you
the sound of this clock
okay so that's the sound of the clock
that actually set the tone for longitude
which again was the first notion of
standardized time standardized geography
and being able to all have you know
again a whole world representation going
on against simultaneously so again
that's another very poignant metaphor
for how the Internet has standardized a
certain kind of perceptual time we all
live in their world of all at once as
Marshall McLuhan said a long time ago
on you know on the screen behind me you
see the definition of the term pattern
it comes from the French term patent
anything proposed for imitation and
archetype and exemplar that which is to
be or is worthy to be copied or imitated
so again the reason I was showing you
guys longitude as a pattern applied to
the whole world it was a sense of how
rhythms are patterns as well right if
you think about rhythm
you know awareness we as humans always
seek out you know the familiar the idea
of even a building is a series of
patterns and there's this very famous
phrase from goethe and schiller these
two german and sort of high Romantic
poets who say architecture is nothing
but frozen music but suppose if we think
of that as patterns architectures and
buildings are nothing but patterns right
and we reverse engineer that term and we
think of music is nothing but liquid
architecture and about patterns and
about the against consistency and
patterns is my artwork it's a it's
always playing with patterns and culture
patterns and memory how these patterns
can be applied to different cultures
which is why I was playing it so the
Indian hip-hop versus WH Auden
and so on and so on here we go here's
another pattern
so again all of these gestures all of
these different fragments of video and
gestures that I'm playing you anyone
could walk away and make any pattern out
of that right this is just one I
particularly chose with a group I work
with call the eclectic method but if I
was in India I would might take a table
pattern and make a riff out of that if I
was in China I might take a people you
know flute or something but each of us
is going to have our own cultural
references and think about patterns and
rhythms in an individual specific way
but hip-hop was one of the first global
vernaculars that influenced so many
people that they all have responded to
those rhythms and that's what I'm
talking about again african-american
identity corporate culture and this idea
of the franchise you know idea for again
equal protection under the law that have
led to the identity of corporations
these are all just patterns and you know
patterns can always be changed and
altered and you just figure it out and
just dive in so the idea here is that
all this is downloadable and I'm hoping
that people will walk away from this
feeling like you know DJ Spooky was here
talking about sort of sampling a
computer or sort of but I'd want you
guys to just walk away from this
thinking it's all about patterns and how
you play with them and that nothing is
cast in stone than that there's always
an irreverence whether it's your DNA
whether it's information whether it's a
presidential speech or whether it's a
painting the idea here is that in
digital in the digital era all these
ideas of a modernist sense of permanence
and static objects these are all now
being put under critique so again from
the idea of the invention of the record
coverage sleeve that I've talked about
earlier to the idea of democratization
of Technology and art and aesthetics
these are issues that youth culture is
dealing with and this is what the idea
of a culture of spookiness of if you
think of again the unhooks the idea of
standardization which are showing you
the cuckoo clock and how each country
plays with the clock these are all
issues that for glow
culture and again digital media culture
in an era where only 50% of the planets
even made a phone call it's something
that's affected everyone let me just
walk you guys through a couple more
things this is again the definition of
rhythm as just I just downloaded from
dictionary combo in awhile ago
it says rhythm here is a movement or
variation characterized by the regular
recurrence or alternation of different
quantities or conditions the rhythm of
the tides for example the patterns
recurring alternations of contrasting
elements of speech or sound so you know
what let me play you guys a typical
example of what I would feel like when I
went into my class you know in college
and we would be talking about Hegel's
dialectics and my professor would be
like wow you know the Socratic method
and being able to understand how
Socrates was was a speaker you know he
would be out in the public square and
they would he would his philosophy
elements and the idea would be able to
be expressed verbally this is the origin
of rhetoric and so I'd say well excuse
me sir that sounds like Chuck D of
Public Enemy and my philosophy said no
no no that's urban youth culture I said
well no Socrates is pretty urban - right
back in a sense you know sort of what
they call the Agora you know being in
the center of the Greek you know town
well the Agora for us has now become the
Internet this idea of again public space
private expression let me let me play
you a typical contrast of what I was you
know kind of a sense of humor I used to
have a radio show called dr. Seuss's
eclectic jungle and so I'd walk into
class and play various mixes of stuff
and they would always I was a trickster
figure for these guys so there was
always a sense of humor but you know
deadly serious let's see if I can find
one of these I bought a whole bunch of
records some of which I've given out and
people are passing around but all right
this is what happens when you have too
many records right all right I can't
find Chuck D right now that's too bad
all right well I will take McLuhan
suppose say for example you would just
feeling like it but you wanted to
here McLuhan sounded like and then we
find a fragment of McLuhan on this
record
thank you
so this is Marshall McLuhan in 1968
reading from the medium is the massage
over a whole bunch of cut-up spliced up
tape recorded loops of jazz rock and the
idea of music as a kind of a theoretical
backdrop so I guess we can call him MC
McLuhan right this is early hip hop this
is actually someone rhyming over a text
being able to try and understand a
structural engagement and recording a
beat and being able to make a
theoretical statement out of it let's
play one or two other examples
so do you get the idea where he's
talking about the idea of the alphabet
as a kind of technology and I'm just
riffing on that you know very specific
quick moment but the idea of movable
type the printable imagination the idea
of a portable language of course what he
called the Gutenberg galaxy has now come
home to roost where we're looking at
each record as a kind of a vernacular
again Lego block and being able to pick
and choose and mix different patterns of
rhythms to come up with different forms
of expression so let's just let McLuhan
talk here with no beat so we were going
to pull him out of a hip-hop vernacular
here for a second able to hang in a
battle with Busta Rhymes but you know
what men thought of themselves how they
adorn each other
it changed systems have come and so on
so that's Frank Lewin talking about the
idea of changing even systems of
government in response to the printing
press and of course we have to Martin
Luther's here Martin Luther who is the
Protestant who posted all of these
proclamations against the reforms of the
Catholic government and we have Martin
Luther King who use posters and other
things to of course protest against the
US as racial policies of the South but
it's kind of a fun pun again mapping one
metaphor onto another one person's name
Martin Luther someone who uses the
Gutenberg Revolution to create an entire
new religious movement and the other
Martin Luther who uses the same kind of
ideas to try and create a different form
of American social culture so from one
Martin Luther to the other the riff the
remix the sample the printing press all
these are metaphors for a culture of the
copy and again since we get we've
probably got to wrap it a little bit I
just want to say you know what at the
end of day it's all spooky so
one one one micro detail if you can pass
the records back so should we should
just open us up the questions I guess
yep that's someone in the back huh the
question I don't know if everybody heard
it was what did I think about the impact
of ebn electronic dance music and the
fact that a lot of record labels are
collapsing and people are downloading
everything and well for me there it's an
ironic situation because I think the
major labels are have to confront the
flag the fact that a lot of them are
based on very flawed models in the first
place and a lot of the musicians aren't
necessarily getting the same payment so
the money goes from where to who you
know I like the itunes model and I like
the way that it's been able to focus
consumer tastes like you might not like
a whole album really you know a lot of
albums I only like one track anyway so
why do you want to drop $18.99 for a
crappy album where you only like this
single or one track it just it allows
for precision of taste that I think is
far more in tune with the idea of the DJ
metaphor in general and I think people
respond to that
it really is creates a richer sense of
culture and it also creates a sense of
of activism and and how people will then
pick and choose what they actually
really want rather than a sort of a
top-down model of you know clearchannel
or you know hot 97 I'm telling you this
is what you like so the pendulum can
swing in either direction really it's
just I definitely think that the major
labels and this idea of the large-scale
kind of pop thing it's here for a while
because a lot they have the branding
there you know once you hear that
Outkast hey-yah song all of a sudden you
just hear it everywhere right but that's
because it's part of his very specific
structure whereas you might not hear the
next rjd2 track or the talbin sing remix
of natasha out those unless you really
go look for it all these are about how
passive versus impassive you are and the
idea for me is not to press play but to
play does that make sense not to just
press play but
actually play and that's where I think
the collapse of the major labels is
going to kind of create a lot more of
these smaller weird boutique labels
internet mp3 groups file-sharing Network
systems and that's going to actually
reconfigure the idea of you know music
culture in general probably within the
next couple of years if not now no well
in hip-hop everybody has this metaphor
of always going to the next level you
know it's just a very ironic thing it
just feels like life and the way that
we've we've imagined the idea of social
hierarchy the way people have
internalized the mechanisms of game
culture if you think about the Indian
game kismet I don't know do you know if
you ever hear this one alright it
actually it was became what they call
snakes and ladders because the the
Indians used it to be able to create a
sense of living in a world of
reincarnation where you're you were
moving from one life to the next and it
was a teaching tool to be able to teach
people about if you are moving through
different levels of life but of course
once it gets to the West it becomes a
game where it snakes and ladders and
it's like you know you have to you know
eat the power manpack pill you know in
pac-man or something and it becomes much
more model about consumer culture and
the idea of kind of trying to always get
more points to get ahead and you know
this kind of you know social Darwinists
metaphor but the videogame for me and
there I use that motif in my artwork
quite a bit because the in the West
we're like we're looking at it you know
a real you know parting of the ways
between how people actually create which
they don't that much anymore and how
people use things so it's about branding
and taste and being able to understand
the levels of hierarchy we see in code
is in society music is just a mirror I
hold up to society you know and the
video game motif say for example you
know a great example considering way I
played you the Bush remix earlier is
this tax cut the Bush's have been doing
with the actual reality is the tax cut
only applies to people maybe over three
hundred to four hundred thousand dollars
income but the rhetoric of what you saw
is making it seem as if it's something
that your average middle-class person
can relate to so again the propaganda
and the illusion has taken on a greater
hold whereas the reality of the what the
actual devastating effect it's becoming
for the government and the ability to
pay things and you're looking at this
huge deficit collapse of all and ideas
of Medicare play out of Yatta Yatta hey
you know what the rhetoric and people
see it on TV and if they relate to it
that's what the people are hoping will
take hold is the myth of it rather than
the actual consequence so that's that's
a game motif you know it's like you know
you're in a labyrinth and you're pac-man
looking for the ghost pill you know the
one that makes you turn invisible the
other ghost or something so anyway to
make a long story short whenever I make
my record coverage sleeves I'm always
thinking about what's going on at that
moment and I always do my design for my
artwork in my albums based on both an
idea of an artistic kind of statement
sometimes about painting sometimes about
computer culture as a metaphor for
culture in general or just for the fact
that you know I just remember when I was
coming up on the scene and Shep was
sticking with his stickers and he kept
having that same image and I just wanted
to keep changing mine so you know it's a
sense of humor hopefully people get it
but there is a theoretical backdrop and
that's what I always try and uh that's I
guess why I'm here at Columbia instead
of DJing at crowbar tonight or something
I don't but uh eventually you know what
you'll be able to press you know a
button on my website and I'll be a
hologram and I'll be chilling out at the
beach and the hologram will be here
lecturing you guys so hopefully that
answers the question
that's a great questions the idea was or
the question was how just to talk about
collaborations and there was one the
Dean of architecture here bernard
tschumi is an old friend of mine I did a
mix and a video for the building the
student center that he designed for the
Venice Biennale in architecture the mix
was played at the at the VN le to me
collaborations are like conversations
I'm always trying to figure out some fun
stuff and sometimes when you're in a
conversation with someone or an hour
project it'll take your artwork or your
creativity to different places that you
wouldn't normally go so if I was just in
my routine and making 12 inches and
album covers I might not get around to
thinking about an architectural
schematic or because it's just you know
I'm too busy and always you know this is
something else taking up my time but if
an architect friend of mine calls up and
says hey you want to do a project let's
figure something out then that that all
of a sudden make me start thinking about
a different approach or a different idea
to make something fun you know it should
be about art as fun and so the the next
magazine I don't know if everybody saw
that it's a very rare it's supposedly on
eBay now bids for like five to seven
hundred bucks but it was a limited
edition CD I did for a magazine that's
called nest it's a very artsy esoteric
magazine where each article it was the
idea of acoustic magazine where I made a
mix for each article and you'd be able
to kind of press play on the CD and
listen to the article so to speak I
wasn't kind of a more of an ambient mix
in the same vein as like a fixed twin
selected ambient works or something like
that but yeah I do collaborations
remixes production so one of the more
controversial remixes I did recently was
a remix of Metallica what I do I do
music for movies a lot and I'm the music
forest spawn which is kind of very
mainstream but that went double platinum
and sold a lot or something it was like
music for the fight scenes in the movie
I need to music for scream - you know
the guy with the ghost and you know you
get you go to some movie theater and
there's this eerie hip-hop music that
was that was me so the idea here is yeah
Duke I do sometimes extremely commercial
work and in a lot of weird artsy
projects
most of the visual material and the kind
of record cover stuff they're seeing
today is all available at the website in
one form or another and the flag cut out
piece for example that's usually I use
from a concert backdrop what I'm doing
large-scale shows so feel free to you
know go back and reverse engineer it on
the CD for example that I gave you guys
hopefully everybody got it if you didn't
there's different versions of it on the
website that you can download is either
real audio or mp3 files but the idea
here is to make your own mix so that's
that's kind of the idea around most of
my artwork it's like the artist as
shareware that's where that one like
kind of always figuring out I work with
many people simultaneously too and I'm
traveling and doing shows also let you
know that if you're interested in this
the idea of open source culture and the
different ways in which art it's a
working with appropriated material and
the kind of increasing tension between
artistic practices of cutting mix
culture sampling appropriation and the
increasingly restrictive intellectual
property regimes in this country
internationally I'll be teaching a
course on those issues in the fall so if
you're back in the fall it's going to be
a 6,000 of course in the school PR so
let's hear it for campus records
the records just pleasing my records
back